ever since Johnny and Mavis had their  little monster I've been the happiest  vampire in the world we have a present  my first guillotine we just have to  baby-proof Valley  she made me baby-proof the whole hotel  we've been talking about moving  somewhere safer for Dennis but then I'll  be all alone yeah don't give me the  pouty bat face we're so happy you came  to visit I love California I'll be sure  remember she's gonna wanna move I gotta  fix this kid now we gotta teach this kid  how to be a monster if we get these  things to come out maybe scantly okay  Marie shown how to be scary oh my back  Oh for real Wow  are we ready to do this  oh yeah hit it are you kidding me  you